bonsoir nous sommes le jeudi 7 avril
merci de nous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition du ces fuites le
journal comme chaque jour nous revenons
sur votre actualité locale entouré de
nous inviter mais également des
journalistes de la rédaction tout de
suite commençons avec les titres de
cette édition
linky c'est le conteur développé par
erdf un compteur communicant connecter
pour mieux maîtriser sa consommation
d'ici 2021 35 millions de lignes qui
seront installés en france
visite du linky lave à nanterre où les
compteurs sont testés commencé le 1er
novembre la trêve hivernale a pris fin
la semaine dernière les expulsions
peuvent recommencer légalement alors que
les problèmes de mal logement persiste
pour nous en parler ce soir charles
henri savourer membre administrateur de
l'association solidarités nouvelles pour
le logement des illuminés notre invité
est enfin dans notre chronique sport du
jeudi focus sur le rugby club de
versailles toujours en course pour le
maintien en fédérale 3 après sa victoire
contre vincennes il est l'application
d'une directive européenne qui a pour
objectif de déployer sur le territoire
des compteurs communicants linky
développé par erdf un compteur
communicant qui permet de recevoir des
ordres et d'envoyer les données à
distance
il permet également aux particuliers de
mieux maîtriser leur consommation
d'énergie un déploiement massif d'ici
2021 sur 90% du territoire français avec
35 millions de compteurs à installer est
prévue williams elle s'est rendue dans
le centre de test pour les yvelines
regarder cent mille foyers en sont déjà
équipés 1 millions le seront à la fin du
mois pour atteindre l'objectif des 35
millions d'ici 2021
voici linky le nouveau compteur
communicant de erdf qui va remplacer
votre ancien compteur et qui s'inscrit
dans le contexte global de la transition
énergétique
il est communicant il est intelligent
dans le sens où effectivement demain
chaque consommateur grâce à lui va
pouvoir être facturée sur la base d'une
consommation réelle et non plus estimé
et donc chaque acteur du coup
marché le consommateur à pouvoir être un
consom'acteur en s'intéressant à sa
facture en regardant en agissant sur sa
consommation les résultats grâce aux
compteurs linky qui va mesurer
exactement sa consommation avec linky le
consommateur pourra analyser sa
consommation sur internet et l'adapter
selon les plages horaires pour erdf plus
besoin de venir relever le compteur
toutes les données seront envoyées
automatiquement chaque jour le projet
linky
c'est un projet qui va être
effectivement financé par erdf
donc c'est gratuit pour le client c'est
un coût global auto financé par
l'entreprise de 5 milliards d'euros
mais le client je le répète lors de la
pause ne payent rien eu aucune
augmentation de factures au moment de la
pose du compteur linky
ici vous êtes howling qu'il appuie un
laboratoire national de erdf pour le
linky qui est pour vocation en fait de
tester le compteur pour s'assurer que sa
durée de vie est bien de 20 ans on est
sûr de l'électronique c'est un vrai défi
technologique
ici les compteurs sont testés dans des
conditions de pénibilité pour s'assurer
du fonctionnement de l'appareil
linky un compteur qui générera dix mille
nouveaux emplois dont 5000 pour
l'installation qui sera fait par des
sociétés locales dans les yvelines les
communes de trappes et les mureaux
seront les premières à en être équipé
dans les deux prochains mois
quant aux craintes de certains usagers
erdf rappelle que linky ne présente
aucun danger pour la santé puisqu'il
fonctionne via un réseau filaire cpl
avec un rayonnement électrique un
millier de fois inférieur à celui d'un
réfrigérateur
nous accueillons ce soir en plateau avec
nous charles-henri de savourer bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
aux gets êtes membre administrateur de
solidarité de nouvelles pour le logement
des yvelines
alors l'association propose les
logements de transition aux personnes
avant qu'elles accèdent à un logement
plus sûr plus on va dire durable
on vient de regarder ce sujet donc
justement sur les lignes qu'il économies
d'énergie c'est important également pour
votre association
oui bien sûr on accueille à un public
par définition défavorisés en difficulté
entre autres financières donc tout ce
qui permet une maîtrise de la
consommation énergétique électrique au
gaz
isolation doussard est une préoccupation
de nous avons donc c'est un pro de
l'actualité qui touche aussi exactement
le logement est aussi les personnes et
hier après s'allumant alors vous êtes
vous êtes ici pour parler de la semaine
donc la trêve hivernale où c'était la
semaine dernière la fin de la trêve
hivernale commence le 1er novembre à la
prise fin donc le 31 mars les expulsions
peuvent donc recommencer légalement en
france entre 30000 et 40 mille foyers
sont concernés et les associations
tirent la sonnette d'alarmé
est ce que c'est votre cas est ce que
solidarités nouvelles pour le logement
sont dites s'inquiètent de cette
situation
alors je dirais qu'on s'inquiète de
cette situation parce que parce que
lucky dix expulsion dix personnes qui
retournent à la rue éventuellement à
l'hôtel ou en hébergement nous as ml on
ne fait pas de logement d'urgence donc
on n'est pas en capacité d'accueillir
directement les gens qui sont expulsés
par contre ces personnes-là rentrer dans
un processus d'attribution et on les
retrouve évidemment dans le dans les
attributions de logements donc on
accueille cette année par an
on a accueilli six personnes qui y
vivent qui venait d'expulsion en fait
alors votre association existe depuis
plus de 25 ans 28 ans si je ne me trompe
pas est ce que au fur et à mesure vous
en faites partie depuis les débuts la
situation s'aggrave
tel est votre analyse par rapport à ça
alors la situation oui la situation
s'aggrave et j'ai envie de dire l e
elle s'améliore aussi quand même parce
qu'il ya des logements qui se font et à
des bénévoles et des citoyens qui se
mobilisent pour ça mais bien sûr la
situation s'aggrave de plus en plus de
personnes qui se retrouvent en
difficulté aujourd'hui la fondation abbé
pierre parle de 3 8 millions de
personnes
en mal logement c'est vrai que nous on
les reçoit pas directement mais c'est
vrai que ça fait beaucoup de monde à la
rue beau coup double en difficulté on a
en parallèle de plus en plus de gens qui
sont dans des situations de de précarité
même s'ils ont dans un même s'ils sont
dans leur propre logement des logiciels
libres des logements en suroccupation
donc évidemment on est concerné
directement alors ces expulsions c'est
évidemment en lien avec donc justement
le mal logement
le manque de logements sociaux et d'y
allemand est ce que c'est le cas dans
les yvelines
oui c'est le cas dans pas mal de
communes des yvelines évidemment on n'a
pas la prétention de on n'a pas la
prétention de résoudre résoudre le
problème du mal logement
ce qui est intéressant dans notre
proposition c'est que c'est une on fait
du logement pour personnes en difficulté
mais ce sont les citoyens c'est une
action citoyenne qui part des citoyens
donc c'est pas les pouvoirs publics et
décide de faire ce sont les habitants
d'un quartier d'une commune qui se
réunissent pour en disant on veut on
veut accueillir chez nous des gens en
difficulté on entend malheureusement
très souvent des gens dire c'est très
bien il faut faire du logement social si
possible dans les communes voisines
nous nos bénévoles disent le contraire
on veut que ce soit près de chez nous
alors justement j'aimerais qu'on
revienne sur votre action vous
définissez comme un nid bailleur social
comment vous vous organisez comment
l'association fonctionne alors
l'association encore une fois démarre
avec des bénévoles donc des citoyens
d'un quartier où d'une commune comme je
disais ces personnes réunissent des
fonds donc vont solliciter leurs amis
leurs relations et apporte environ 20%
du prix d'un appartement ils achètent un
appartement enfin l'association achète
un appartement avec ces fonds avec
l'aide de ses bénévoles et donc on a des
salariés qui travaillent évidemment là
dessus et ensuite une fois que
l'appartement est acheté donc ça mais
quand même pas mal de temps on le les
bénévoles qui se réunit en ce qu'on
appelle nous en groupe local de
solidarité accueil la famille ou la
personne logé dans son logement pour
l'aider à sa s'intégrer dans le quartier
à apprendre à habiter je dirais et serez
permettre l'accès plus tard un logement
durable
alors il ya toute une démarche
d'accompagnement faut travailler ces
niveaux a vraiment de l'appartement de
la réflexion de l'appartement alors on a
toute une et on a évidemment un gros si
on peut faire du logement parce qu'on
fait du logement évidemment très peu
cher si on peut le faire c'est aussi
parce qu'on a des bénévoles et on a
entre autres ce qu'on appelle des
équipes travaux donc des bénévoles qui
vont intervenir pour les petites
réparations que jamais dire habituel
parfois pour des remises en état plus
importante et ça nous fait évidemment
des gains de temps des coûts moindres
et ça permet en plus de sa d'accompagner
les familles de faire du relationnel de
créer du lien et d'apprendre
éventuellement apa le qatar a travaillé
chez eux à bricoler chez eux
il ya une vraie solidarité citoyenne
vous faisais c'était des prix très bas
qui était pratiqué ce que vous pouvez
nous en parler ou thermique est
justement aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
le prix moyen du délogement que nous
proposons c'est de l'ordre de 6 euros
c'est entre 6 et 8 euros le mètre carré
ces accès à peu près deux à trois fois
moins cher selon les communes
par définition aussi on s'entend nous on
est implanté plus tôt dans les communes
favorisés on va pas aller créer des
nouveaux logements sociaux dans les
communes où il ya déjà
40 ou 50 % de logements sociaux c'est
pas notre objectif c'est vraiment de les
faire là où il y en a pas donc c'est
vraiment le travail des bénévoles de
faire ça aujourd'hui dans les yvelines
vous avez trouvé des logements pour
combien de personnes ne sais pas si vous
avez des chiffres par rapport sur une
année où sur 50
aujourd'hui dans les yvelines on a 115
logements
on a on est en gère 115 logements on a
des logements en pleine propriété et on
a également
quelques beaux arrêts habilitation avec
des particuliers on a des mises à
disposition aujourd'hui il existe une
multitude de possibilités pour faire du
logement accessible aux plus démunis et
voilà nous étudions toutes les
possibilités donc nous avons centre 115
logements
aujourd'hui nous avons à peu près cent
huit familles logées additionnel alors
justement comment sont choisis ces
familles comment était le processus un
petit peu voilà bien pour avoir accès
justement ces logements
alors c'est pas nous qui choisissons
directement les familles les familles
passent par les services sociaux
habituels des communes et
en général par la mairie il y à une
organisme qui s'appelle le siao qui
étudie les différentes candidatures pour
vous donner une idée quand on a un
logement qui se libère il ya une
commission qui se réunit sous la
présidence du siao donc et il y aura à
peu près entre 20 et 25 candidatures
pour chaque logement
donc nous on nous propose une
candidature et on la reçoit on lui
propose note on lui fait notre
proposition propositions
d'accompagnement on précise que c'est un
logement temporaire puisque dans fait de
logements temporaires et si on est tous
d'accord on signe un contrat
alors justement on fait du logement
temporaire logement passerelle pour
après accompagner les gens vers un
logement plus durable combien de temps
ils peuvent justement rester dans ce
logement pascal transitoire alors on n'a
pas de on n'a pas de on n'a pas de délai
prévu au départ on signe toujours un
contrat d'un an ont leurs nouvelles
j'ai envie de dire le temps nécessaire
pour que la personne
accès d'un logement de droit commun donc
aujourd'hui la moyenne ces trois ans
mais on a par exemple cette année
reloger trois familles qui était chez
nous depuis huit ans et on a relogé la
semaine dernière une famille qui était
là depuis moins de quatre mois
donc c'est vraiment très variable mais
la moyenne ces trois ans ce sont des
familles des familles nombreuses des
parois isolées qu'elles sont le genre de
personne que vous accompagnez alors ça
un petit peu évolué on a eu beaucoup on
peut avoir des gens qui viennent on a eu
par le passé plusieurs fois des gens qui
venaient de la rue on a là un tout petit
peu moins
on a aujourd'hui beaucoup de familles
monoparentales beaucoup de femmes avec
enfants femmes seules avec enfants de
très jeunes femmes seules on a des
familles parfois nombreuses trois quatre
cinq enfants
voilà on est en capacité d'accueillir en
fonction de nos appartements j'ai envie
de dire tous les publics à partir de
monde ils rentrent dans les critères
entre guillemets très modeste soit une
population plus jeune parce que c'est
vrai qu'on parle beaucoup de précarité
haut niveau voilà des jeunes des
étudiants ou des dés promet des plaintes
qui commence à entrer dans la vie active
et qui ne peuvent pas forcément se loger
avec les bas salaires alors on n'a pas
tellement ça on n'a pas beaucoup de je
crois pas qu'on ait d'étudiants par
exemple si ya pas tellement notre projet
notre projet c'est plutôt les gens qui
ont vu un accident un accident de
parcours je dirais donc
c'est plutôt des familles ou des très
jeunes mamans qui se retrouvent à la rue
parce qu'elles ont un enfant et qui est
voilà n'ont pas de logement
expulsé de la famille ou voilà mes
étudiants par exemple je pense pas qu'on
en est c'est pas tellement notre la
proposition connard vous arrivait
justement à faire à ses actions avec des
dons avec l'aide aussi des bénévoles
vous recherchez justement des bénévoles
dont sur le territoire saint quentin en
yvelines dans les îles ou plus
globalement
alors on est implanté évidemment à saint
quentin en yvelines on est implanté dans
24 communes de la discipline
principalement dans la région de
versailles saint quentin mais on a par
exemple aujourd'hui un nouveau groupe
qui se créa sa rambouillet donc
évidemment on cherche des bénévoles on
cherche des nouveaux groupes
notre action je voulais dit à l'heure et
démarrent à partir de bénévoles pas de
bénévoles pas de logement pas de groupe
local paddl pas d'accueil donc à dans
l'est à rambouillet parents prenaient un
groupe qui vient de commencer
on cherche évidemment des nouveaux
bénévoles on cherche évidemment des
donateurs on a quand même des donateurs
très généreux mais c'est vrai que plus
on a de donateurs plus on aura de de
possibilité d'acheter des appartements
il ya donc des dons des mécènes est ce
que vous allez aussi vous dépendez des
dotations de l'état du conseil
départemental
oui alors non on n'en dépend de janvier
de deux façons sur la partie
investissement
nos appartements seront financées en
partie par les pouvoirs publics en
partie assez importante puisque c'est
plus de 50%
donc là on n'est pas trop impacter parce
que le financement de la pierre marche
plutôt bien
là où on est assez fortement impacté
c'est sûr le plus tôt sur le le
l'accompagnement en fait on nous avons
trois travailleurs sociaux dans
l'association qui sont financés par
procédé en partie par le conseil
départemental et là c'est vrai que les
dotations sont en baisse importante
on est obligé de
voilà de se réadapter pour pourra pour
accompagner les familles le mieux
possible avec les moyens que nous avons
qui sont conséquents mais qui nous
permettent pas de faire le travail qu'on
aimerait pouvoir faire la baisse des
dotations va impacter si on veut être
bénévole pour la solidarité nouvelle
pour logements verront vous rejoindre
quelle est la démarche à faire la
démarche à faire c'est simple c'est de
trouver un groupe local ou de rejoindre
le groupe vocal ci en est là à côté de
chez vous sinon sinon vous avez vous
avez le site internet
snl ti réunion point org là vous allez
arriver sur le site de l'ensemble des
associations nationales puisqu'il ya
cinq associations nationales en ile de
france vous cliquez sur le lien yvelines
et vous nous rejoignez comme ça où vous
pouvez passer voir l'association qui est
basé au chan est très bien et bien
l'appel a été entendu merci beaucoup de
chaleur et savourer d'être venu sur
notre plateau foncier autre sujet à
présent ce matin et toute la journée
l'iut de vélizy accueilli la deuxième
édition du colloque en diversité
organisé par l'université paris saclay
l'événement rassemblé une vingtaine
d'ingénieurs venus présenter leurs
projets d'innovation autour du handicap
un secteur économique encore trop peu
exploitées selon ces entrepreneurs
camille lambert était sur place regarder
depuis trois ans marie claire un
handicap mais il ne se voit pas à la
suite d'un traumatisme crânien elle a dû
réapprendre les gestes du quotidien
aujourd'hui elle a fait le déplacement
au colloque en diversité à l'iut de
vélizy pour tester bcap un logiciel
permettant d'analyser sa conduite
automobile
ça change des évaluations
mais guérir et salaires
c'était le temps de faire mes courses
très bien comme à n'importe qui même en
étant est bien visible de 7 ans selon
l'insee sur les 12 millions de français
handicapés 80% à handicap invisible
comme marie claire organisée par
l'université paris saclay cet événement
avait pour but de montrer le handicap
comme vecteur d'innovation technologique
prendre en compte le handicap en amont
permet de faire des produits beaucoup
plus innovant est bien plus intéressant
pour tous on a tous un jour ou l'autre
besoin d'une assistance donc autant y
penser en amont alors qu est essentielle
ment s'adresse aux chercheurs aux
entrepreneurs à tous ceux qui ont envie
de développer des projets qui permettent
d'avoir une société ouverte à tous
c'est s'ouvrir à un marché extrêmement
grand dans lequel tout le monde peut se
retrouver ou donc il ya effectivement
des potentiels à créer applications pour
personnes malvoyantes ou simulateur de
fauteuils roulants
une vingtaine d'ingénieurs ont présenté
leur projet avec démonstrations
celui ci on peut l'utiliser dans
plusieurs optiques d'abord dans une
petite de sensibilisation en fait dans
une optique d'apprentissage pour les
personnes qui ont récemment handicapés
puis tout simplement pour les
architectes pour pouvoir vérifier
l'accessibilité de certains lieux
publics
en fauteuil roulant la majorité des
projets présentés sont encore en phase
de test avant leur entrée sur le marché
en 2015 l'insee estimait que 50 % des
français sont ou seront confrontés au
handicap pour eux mêmes ou pour un de
leurs proches et l'atelier des sciences
propose jusqu'au 24 avril prochain à la
commanderie des templiers d'elancourt
une exposition en partenariat avec
escales des sciences de l'université de
lorraine deux expositions pour le prix
d'une corps en images permet de
découvrir l'évolution des
représentations du corps au cours de
l'histoire et corps tangible la deuxième
exposition met en avant les possibilités
du corps en mouvement
regardez ce reportage signé sephora
namani et mélanie poté pardon encore
tangibles et corps en images des
expositions en une pour mieux
appréhender le fonctionnement du corps
humain
la première réalisée par escales des
sciences propose un voyage anatomique
qui conduit des représentations antiques
du corps à son approche médicale
contemporaine grâce à l'imagerie la star
de l'exposition c'est ce vidéo mapping
la vidéo mapping qu'est ce que c'est
c'est un type de vidéos où on travaille
de manière très précise
la projection et on a plusieurs niveaux
en fait de discours et de d'information
projeté donc là par exemple vous pouvez
voir sur le corps vraiment ce que l'on
voit avec chacune des techniques
d'imagerie médicale c'est-à-dire ici il
ya quatre techniques d'imagerie médicale
qui sont présentés les rayons x et
résonance magnétique les ultrasons
radioéléments efflorescence en classe
fac
l'expérience se poursuit avec
l'exposition corps tangibles et quatre
veaux numérique comportementale invite
le visiteur à jouer avec l'ombre de son
corps pour créer en direct des visuels
géant qui s'affiche sur écran pour ce
faire on utilise des éléments de jeux
vidéo des kinect
l'un d'eux précis on expérimente on le
vit on est à là on est vraiment dans des
oeuvres projetées
ce sont des grands systèmes de l'image
projetée
civ dans lequel le visiteur peut
interagir c'est à dire qu'il passe dans
un espace est là en fait son image
captée et elle est traitée une voie
artistique dans la projection on voit
son image que d'abord interprété en
marge de cette exposition des mini
ateliers permettent de découvrir à
l'intérieur du corps et comme chaque
jeudi vous le savez c'est le moment de
la chronique sport d'autres journalistes
sportifs et mickaël mille euros on sort
michael alors quel est le thème de votre
chronique aujourd'hui
alors aujourd'hui je vous parlais du
rugby-club de versailles et plus
particulièrement de l'équipe senior en
fédérale 3 les joueurs de la cité royale
sont sortis de la zone de relégation
après une victoire contre vincennes sur
le score de 16 à 14 le week-end dernier
menés de 14 points au bout de dix
minutes de jeu les verse ayant su réagir
devant plus de 500 spectateurs
conséquence les bleus ne sont pas encore
enterré dans ce championnat on écoute la
réaction du président du club olivier
hahn air neufs est encore encore un
espoir la bête n'est pas complètement
morte
l'arrêt ne sont pas que ne s'est pas
encore véritablement en fait mais il
faudra avoir le couteau entre les dents
pour pouvoir les jeux ea ou soeurs et ça
sera quand même très très très compliqué
alors je vais vous planter le décor
floral ce soir la dernière journée du
championnat de fédérale 3 auxerre a
remporté 15 de ses 17 matches disputés
cette saison les bourguignons ont 10
points d'avancé sur leur dauphin de
l'autre côté nous avons versailles avec
trois petites victoires cette saison et
qui compte 53 points de moins que
versailles
vous l'aurez compris se sont un peu le
remake de david contre goliath
surtout que auxerre jouera à domicile
olivier nero 9 en a conscience
c'est énorme énorme avec un budget qui
est de 705 150000 euros avec des
trentenaires dans la mêlée qui sont
georgia roumains italiens écossais et
qui sont les rois du groupé pénétrant et
ne sont que des groupés pénétrants pour
tout est un des pénalités trop d
touchera faire des groupés pénétrants
est allé jusqu'à l'en-but donc très
compliqué quand ton équipe jeune et
qu'on a pas dynamique c'est très
compliqué
devant leur public ils pourront pas se
permettre d'avoir
le moindre l'homme la moindre défaite
donc à mon avis ça va être très
compliqué pour renverser la montagne
auxerroises les versions trois semaines
pour se préparer et soigner les pépins
physiques contre va survenue contre
vincennes le coach baptiste gouache
devrait compter sur un groupe au complet
les versailles et vont jouer leur chance
à fond
on a dit qu'on allait y aller le couteau
entre les dents on n'a pas fait tout
cette saison avec des nuances très
compliqué pour essayer de tout lâcher
avant l'été on nagera mais à la fin du
match
que se passera-t-il en cas de contre
performance on peut dire que c'est un
match qui tu n'oublies pas forcément
florennes s'il verse à y perdre contre
auxerre ils devront attendre le résultat
de pont-à-mousson et de vincennes pour
savoir si oui ou non ils descendent en
honneur versailles sera donc les scores
sur les téléphones ou sur les réseaux
sociaux en cas de descente olivier nero
9 en est persuadé ses joueurs ses
protégés remonteront en fédérale 3 dès
la saison prochaine
j'ai aussi ce redoutable avantage depuis
si longtemps dans ce club
50e année cette année consécutive donc
j'en ai fait des montent et descendent
en tant que joueur j'en ai fait aussi
les montées descentes entre dirigeants
on est remonté en 2008
donc ça sera pas si dramatique même je
veux dire si la concurrence est toujours
très compliqué en honneur mais nous on a
des jeunes en a pour laura guénard
rangers et je pense que d'ici deux trois
ans on aura notre résurrection
le match est donc programmée le 24 avril
prochain sur le terrain d'auxerre on
leur souhaite évidemment de gagner ce
match et de se maintenir florennes eh
bien on va croiser les doigts pour eux
le 24 avril et maintenant on va à
présent ranger le ballon ovale pour
parler de lamballe
c'est un petit peu la même situation que
le rugby club de versailles monty les
féminines de montigny le bretonneux
affronte ce samedi à 20h30 pessacais
dans un match à quitte ou double dernier
du classement lésigny montaigne doivent
l'emporter contre le 9e du classement
pour encore espérer une victoire devrait
permettre à montigny de sortir de la
zone rouge à cinq journées de la fin du
championnat pour les soutenir
rendez-vous au complexe sportif pierre
de coubertin
et oui flore vous suivez bien on le
verra plus jusqu'en à septembre sur les
parcs et de nationale 3 après cette
rencontre trappe sixième du classement
affronte malakoff pour la dernière
journée du championnat de nationale 3
les trappistes
auront à coeur de remporter le match
pour terminer la saison dans les cinq
premiers ils partiront favoris avec leur
duo flamboyant abgué barakaou et joey
casseus cette rencontre est programmée
ce samedi à 20 heures au gymnase paul
mallet voilà floral vous connaissez les
rendez vous sportifs à ne pas manquer ce
week end le département j'espère que je
vous ai donné envie d'aller dans les
gymnases évinoise ou bien sûr et comme
d'habitude vous savez miquel j'ai tout
noté dans mon agenda rejet survient à
vous vous retrouvez la semaine prochaine
pour la chronique sport est aussi lundi
dans mes s'épuise pas voilà que ce tweet
sport voilà il sera question notamment
de adil abou madi l'élan courtois qui a
perdu contre calomnie smith samedi
dernier avec nous au plateau quelle
chance on a hâte de voir ça merci à
michael passons maintenant à france
miniature le parc situé l encours se
prépare à sa réouverture chaque année il
accueille plus de 170 mille visiteurs
venus parfois des quatre coins du monde
nous sommes allés au parc afin de suivre
les dernières estimations et les
derniers préparatifs du parc qui fête
cette année ses 25 ans c'est celle du
fossé seul
j moins 3 pour les équipes de france
miniature ils sont douze à travailler en
plein hiver avec l'ouverture qui
approchent ils sont une trentaine
d'employés à bichonner et monuments dès
le lendemain de la fermeture on va
démonter certaines maquettes qui vont
être repeintes en atelier on va
déménager les maquettes les plus
fragiles pour les abriter
voilà ce qui nous occupe les trois 3
semaines suivant la fermeture travail en
atelier et puis dès que les beaux jours
reviennent on essaye tout début mars de
renvoyer ce matériel repeint sur le site
pour être prêts cette année le 9 avril
avant d'être réinstallé les monuments
passe dans l'atelier pour se refaire une
beauté si le cas chaque année de 20 à 25
maquette sur les plus de 2000 que compte
le parc
ici on ne construit pas de maquette en
fait des petites réparations ont fait
beaucoup de peinture une peinture une
patine ce qu'on appelle c'est la
peinture extérieure sur une maquette
elle va raisonnablement tenir en
extérieur pendant quatre cinq ans mais
cette année la réouverture a une saveur
particulière le site ouvert en 1991 fête
ses 25 ans un quart de siècle de
modification à 25 ans elle a beaucoup
évolué à son départ il ne se consacrer
qu'à la france et des maquettes et début
des années 2000 dans l'idée de divertir
un petit peu plus nos visiteurs le parc
à installer huit attractions voir un
petit avoir un moment de défoulement un
moment plus loisirs au milieu de la
visite
et depuis trois ans nous installons au
milieu de la visite au milieu des
maquettes d animation interactive et
pédagogique qui nous permettent de
raconter la france d'une autre façon
d'aller sur le domaine de de l'industrie
une grotte préhistorique un chantier de
fouilles pas de nouvelles maquettes mais
des rendez-vous spéciaux pour cet
anniversaire des animations commencent
dès le mois d'avril
les équipes ont encore quelques détails
à peaufiner trois jours pour tout régler
la tour eiffel elle est déjà bien
installée c'est la fin de cette émission
merci de nous avoir suivis demain
nouvelle édition du journal l'essentiel
de l'actualité avec wilfrid est riche et
vous retrouverez mélanie potel vous
donnera avec ses invités de nombreuses
idées de sorties
dans le set fit le week end je vous
souhaite une bonne soirée et un
excellent 8e
ce